We have a right circular cone with a shaded base.
And we will try to derive a formula for the surface area of a cone.
Let us name the points O, A, B.
Points A and B are marked on the circumference
such that AB forms a diameter.
Let 'l' be the slant height and 'h' be the perpendicular height.
And let 'r' be the radius of the circular base.
First, let us consider the circular base.
The radius of the circular base is 'r'.
So it's area will be 'pi r squared'.
Next we need to find the area of the curved surface.
And we have seen that when the curved surface is opened up,
it looks like a sector.
We also need to find the area of the sector.
Let the sector be O, A, B.
Look at the sector and the cone.
What do you think is the measure of these two lengths?
'OA' and 'OB' will equal the slant height which is 'l'.
Here's another interesting question.
What will be the length of arc AB?
This is an arc as we know that a sector is a part of the circle.
This arc is actually the circumference of the circular base.
So the length of this arc will be '2 pi r' .
A sector is also defined by the angle it subtends at the center.
Let us call it 'theta'.
Now we are ready to find the area of the sector!
And it gets even more interesting.
There is another way in which we can find the length of the arc 'AB'.
Let's zoom out to look at the other way.
It will equal 'theta by 360'
multiplied by the circumference of the circle with radius 'OA' and 'OB'.
What will be the circumference of the circle
that is formed with this as the sector?
It will be '2 pi l',
since 'l' is the radius of the circle of which this sector is a part.
This tells us that the length of the arc AB
is a part of the circumference of the big circle that can be formed here.
But the length of arc AB is also '2 pi r'.
That will equal 'theta by 360' multiplied by '2 pi l'.
Cancelling '2 pi' out from both sides,
we get 'r' equal to 'theta by 360' multiplied by 'l'.
The area of this sector will be the curved surface area of this cone.
The area of this sector will equal 'theta by 360'
multiplied by the area of the circle with 'OA' and a 'OB' as the radius.
And that will be 'pi l squared' as 'l' is the radius of this circle.
Can we write this a bit differently?
Yes, this can also be written as 'pi l' multiplied by
'theta by 360' multiplied by 'l'.
We have just split 'pi l squared', into 'pi l' multiplied by 'l'.
But this part in brackets as which is found out is equal to 'r'.
So the curved surface area will be 'pi l' multiplied by 'r'.
Let us review what we just did.
We found out the length of arc AB
in two different ways and equated them.
And then we found out the curved surface area
using the formula of a sector of a circle.
And then finally substituted the value of 'r' in this formula
to eliminate 'theta'.
Now, it's very simple!
The total surface area of the cone
will be the curved surface area
plus the area of the circular base.
The curved surface area as we know is 'pi l r'.
And the area of the base is 'pi r squared'.
Both the terms have 'pi r' as their common factor.
Taking 'pi r' common, we write the formula as 'pi r'
multiplied by 'l plus r'.
This is the formula for the total surface area of a right circular cone.